double up is obviously one of the
highlights of victory lap
what can you tell us about your
your role in that record and how that
record came came out man that was a
beautiful evening man um
nip had you know he was working on his
album we went from like you know on the
come up and in the times where we was
really working together we worked
together heavy like damn near every day
for like a couple years all the time you
know and then
um when they got the deal with atlantic
and i was doing other stuff i had
traveled and did a couple tours
and i hadn't really seen nip as much for
like a little window besides like shows
he came to one of my festivals in
anaheim
um might have been day and night i don't
know at the angel stadium yeah i
remember that was a big one yeah he came
out and showed up for me um
and then a little bit after that you
know he was working on the album the
whole time though that's one thing i
could say like he took his time with
victor always focused like about that
album and being adamant about it coming
out one day how it was because i
remember having combos with him
years ago and him playing me songs that
was still on our ideas that were you
know way before
that album came out so
you know in the midst of all of that you
know i would see bro and um he was like
man come
i got i want to play the album he was he
was camped out at uh
what's the spot on vine you know it uh
paramount he used to have his whip right
there and pair on the curb everybody
know that knowing
i went up there one day and he was like
yeah you know the music i'm just vibing
just listening showing my support he was
getting tatted it was funny because i
remember he was getting blasted
the big arm money in on that was a part
of the rollout he took his shirt off a
lot on the campaign so i was there
tonight he was getting blasted and he
was playing me songs
and um he was like man really i just got
one verse song that i really really love
that i haven't
did two verses but that could make the
album man he played it and i just went
right in the booth and i remember he was
getting tired he was smiling just
looking at me you know i mean recording
i'll never forget that and i could just
see him through the window and he was
like listening to what i was saying and
he was getting tatted and um it was just
a cool night man and the next time i
really heard the song i really found out
you know how it went down was really
when they're released
then at the release party yeah exactly
and then hearing you know exactly what
belly had added to it and just the final
project man and i just thought it was
like the highest quality you know not
that that's not that's what i expect
from it but
i was really floored by how well you
know he was able to weather the storm
and really get his vision all the way
out on the highest level man i'll
forever be proud of him for that yes
it might be my favorite song of victory
lap it's one of them but it's crazy
because like i just think like what if
nip was still here and he was over there
at chalice with
what's going on at hit boy spot like i'm
like
what's in the middle that's what i'm
saying like they just were getting they
were just getting their they're like you
know what i'm saying like just imagine
the crazy collabs
i know i think about it every day man
that was the last place i saw him and
spoke to him at
in hit boy um studio
finishing racks in the middle yep you
know it's crazy man yeah r.i.p
the great